Yeah, start it.
So…
I think…
So, the…
So the first thing…
Uh, was it regarding the training data?
So, uh, Leo, if you want to kind of…
elaborate on that.
So…
It's basically, uh, he… there was a list of things that he had. He was saying that he could start with, uh, even without those, but…
It would be great if we could have the…
the label, like, what input goes to what output, and what output.
Do you want to add anything there?
So, when you look at you with some leadership, right?
Yeah, yeah. I guess.
Yeah, I think it was sent to everyone.
So… yeah.
Yeah, so I thought that…
Yes, um…
The 6th of April.
And it includes a whole bunch of stuff.
You have it?
Do you have the… do you have the amount?
It was sent to you. We could forward it back to you.
Oh, favorite request on the 46 of FTU, and uh… You know, we can't find it, I'm gonna resend it.
Yeah. And providing information you asked for.
And I also, like, I think in the last meeting I posted it.
I'll hear about you.
It's this close, so…
It's the… I think what happened was that he was looking for a fresh email instead of, like, a blank cell, so yeah, it did have it.
Yeah.
No. You remember, like, if you just see…
I was responding to your email.
I don't even know who you're asking that.
Yeah, indeed.
started using a bunch of words. Here's my inbox, and it pulls emails.
Good idea.
So…
For these, I think you can just ask them, like…
No, they're going through. Yeah.
Yeah, correctly.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, so you can just port…
Yeah.
Like, you just use the Android.
So it should work.
Yes, I am.
Are you not able to contact me, let me just see…
Yeah.
So I guess the real question would be is how large is the data set?
It's…
I don't know if they wanted to focus on a specific product.
I'm saying this is basically for everything.
So, they can pick and choose what they want to look like.
Okay. I mean, I wouldn't, I wouldn't aim to have that story.
You want them drinking on a fertilizer. Come on.
Yeah, I think he's not able to access, that's the thing. But, you know, we'll see.
Yeah.
What was this one?
I think that was the issue, though.
include, like, the CS.
Okay, yeah.
Other than that…
Yeah, there was one other thing. Uh, we're… Lou, he started work on it, and he's…
Yeah, but uh… he also mentioned that
the Claude, uh, Crokin limit as a…
running out pretty fast. You'd think he ran out within 20 minutes or something, so…
So, um, today is…
Yeah. I'll probably implement, like,
usage policy, but keep the limits the same. Yeah, yeah. So, I mean, if you guys…
More than that?
Yeah, yeah.
Uh… yeah, I don't think because, uh…
that portion is the one that's really heavy right now. Everyone else is more…
Regarding making documents and stuff, so…
You know, I don't think we're gonna hit that really soon.
Yeah.
Yeah, that good advice.
I hope you came back and forth.
And you can also, uh…
as we go along.
enterprise queue, where you have a team.
Oh. So now we just have, like…
Um, and you'll be rich for every single week.
I did not know that.
So, is the… still, like,
the whole group policy possible, sort of, like, all the…
So, let me see if I can…
Okay, so it's a pay-as-you-go policy with skills.
which they completely worked out.
Yeah.
I guess I've been facing a lot of outages with Clark, so I think the demand might be too much on there.
use it every time, which is not a 9 to 5.
Got it.
Um, Google.
I'm already recording it.
Oh.
Yeah, there's a trick people are finding where you start with the conversation before dying.
started outside, even though you're using it during 95.
Because now you can't even start a session on that, because…
There's so many people using technology, right?
And these values can be very good.
Yeah, um… Credit, I just got the email for ODEX, yeah.
I'm making the count right now.
I already have way too many accounts for all this AI stuff, but I'm making a new one.
They sent it both to my previous university at UMass, and…
This one as well, so I'm making two accounts right now.
Uh, they've not… they've not, like, closed down my previous whatsoever.
Might as well.
Uh, yeah, those were the two things that
I think when I was talking with Liam, that, you know, when he was making it that he raised them.
And, uh, I was also unsure about, like,
how the group thing would work, isn't it?
Other than that, uh, we're pretty much working on the ML portion right now. Leo, he's made some progress, and…
But the training still has to be done.
I don't think the training's done right. Yeah, it's done. So…
We have the previous one and this one, so that's… that's about that.
I would just suggest that you guys should take some time off.
understanding how to just use AI tools again.
Yeah. Because I think there's a lot of, uh…
It's a lot to learn more than just a lot to understand.
Because, uh, for example, just when it comes to, like, token usage or context management, there's just so much better.
So the thing is, if you're using an only chat,
And you're trying to…
You just use regularly to explain everything that you work on.
And every single time we technically open up a new section,
I'm a bit enthused. I think there's an echo.
Ashuta.
Should be fine, yeah, this is fine. Sorry about that. So when you're talking about the context service, right? So.
If you have already had a previous conversation, doesn't it just compact into working there? No, it has compacted, but the thing is, for example, if you're asking me about the unrelated question.
Or a question which is very, like, slightly related to the current conversation. It looks still compact, all of the conversations that happened before, so instead of just using the 20 words that you send right now, if you use 20 plus 400, 500 words that you used before.
Got it, so it still tries to relate, and I've seen it. So that would be like a bigger token that's been sent. I've also been facing a few issues, but I'm just not. I guess.
how the… how it's like using the previous context. So it's not totally transparent, but you… there's, like, a few ways, or just practices which you can use to do, which is not that happens.
And those practices might just help you guys a little bit.
It is not in the inventory. Just to. I'd like to have a common set of best practices. You can just obviously you can just go on YouTube and or even if Claude has free courses which they give out. Those courses are like how much an hour long, or like an hour and a half.
Yeah. And you can visit a little better. I think we did a couple of those participatory.
Uh, the studio has two courses that, uh, we were basically part of the work that we do, and I think you get a kind of search experience. Yeah.
So yeah, I've not gone through all of them, but probably should so much. It's changed me so there's too much change, there's too much to keep up, and that's that's kind of a problem, too. Yeah, it's Lord released us 4.7, right? Like.
half an hour, 30 minutes ago, uh, ChatGPT, like, uh, oh god, actually, something.
I think we backed up all my data as I heard about that.
cybersecurity news about the finding those. Yeah, I didn't even think that open DSD was even possible to like do anything much less crash it from anywhere.
It's also like to say. Yeah, sure. Yeah. Uh, we do have an updated SOW. So Cliff has just given some more feedback on that as well. So… I will like correct correct that and show like an updated version. So should we have digital signature on it, or should I print out and show it like for signatures? I'm not sure.
Well, ideally, you know, you want to go through the process of doing the S1 to getting the client to provide their input on it. You know, you can do electronic signing, you can do physical signing. The whole idea is just to make sure that you have some sort of thing that people acknowledging that this current version is available.
I don't know what you guys are sending it to.
I'll still have to update it with his feedback, but I will be sending it to you anyway as well.
Yeah, I'll go through it again. I went through the last one and I had a few comments, but I just said.
I should have like there. There's the it was not as up to the there. There was a template that I could have used that that's much more in line with what CV uses. So it did forward like a lot of examples. So I I read using it.
I think it's a lot better than previously. So just send us to the exam first. Yeah. Examples are good. I mean, the the whole point here is the exercise of doing it. It's it's not a legal document, but it's it's a good exercise for the team to do.
It's good to contribute good taxes. Now, check what we're getting. Yeah.
Other than that… So, we actually… So, we're still, I guess we're starting off into the South recording, I guess, and South Temple part.
So we actually don't have a lot to show right now. It's still. And yeah, I was a bit hesitant. I considered… Uh… Maybe, like, uh, you know, that the meeting might be short, but we actually are kind of in the weeds right now, so it would take a bit before we can show, like, some of the things that we actually at least I wasn't expecting anything until like summer started.
So that's… that's okay. I think right now, we've been working a bit on the architecture side of things, and we had a few… Any ideas on how to architecting. Uh, right now we had a… I think we've not finalized, but we have a basic structure in mind. I think we will be discussing the car architecture coach. We had a conversation before as well, and he had a few review points, and we can go back to him. I think.
By the end of this month, we'll have a… I've got a little bit of more ground-level architecture.
So currently, it's going to be pipe and filter kind of thing, because it is pretty sequential. The process that we have.
There are a few open points, like the ML, how you can use it, but that's anybody going to come into one component. Yeah, exactly. So, uh, like, the architecture-wise, we should be good, uh, to start developing, uh, the next time, start late.
Yeah. Probably the other thing to to be aware of. This is something that's new to us is that you know, normally at this point we are coming up on the semester presentations, and it looks like they're doing something different this year. They're doing crits, not in semester presentation. So I'll have to check and find out what what with the.
The engagement with clients is at all for these crits or not, so that can be good. I mean, it was always good to have the instructor just to get a sense of what was going on, where they're going, what the plan is for the future, but we're having a meeting with all the mentors tomorrow, so I'll bring that question.
Good. Yeah, I mean, Sasha sent across an email asking us about their availability, and she did mention that explicitly that.
It's not… it's not necessary to, like, $10… we don't really, uh, think.
There's no, like, kind of rules to the next story. And she also mentioned the word thing. Yeah. That was good.
Yeah, um, yeah, semester's ending, I guess there's more things all at once.
Uh, other than that, uh… No one else has something to add. Because I've mentioned all the points that I'm curious about your last trip to e parts. I had offered to give you a ride at my car died again, so how did you get there? Yeah, he's taken over. Okay.
Yeah, that's the perfect thing going to fix, and we're gonna get cracked again. So we'll have another meeting so we can get you. Yeah.
individual coils for each park plug and and those those that have tried those didn't work. You got to go back and get the expensive, unfortunately.
So you want to reliable transportation. So I apologize, and I do look forward to coming out sometime.
I think, um, from the last meeting, what can discuss for the PIMS architecture, like, now, even after, like, that meeting, I personally don't have any questions. Whatever I had was asking immediately, so… Yeah, I think the meeting related to the architecture part as well. So now we have a much more clarity about the options and how all those things are gonna work. Yeah. I think the next question we'll probably have is when we start writing something down, then that's when we'll be able to summer is probably when we'll be working together as well.
Yeah. I don't know, did you clue him in with the injury to one of your teammates or not? I don't know what happened. He was, uh, he had a scooter accident, and then he was pretty bad injured. So that's why he's not with us right now. I mean, he is with us right now, but he's not like him. He's not physically in the room. Sorry.
My choice, of course. I realized it after I spoke. What's the mistake?
Hey! Hi, guys.
He's on the call. He's on the call.
So what is your, uh, plans for going back to India and getting your dental work? Yeah.
Uh, I think I'll be traveling the end of this month, and then I'll be in India for, like, 2-3 weeks.
But, uh, I don't think there'll be any disruption in the entire workflow, though.
I will just be taking meetings from India itself.
At the same time, so…
Should be all good.
I realize I spoke the wrong last time. It's apathy. Yeah. Physically. Yeah, that's that's what that was my opinion.
Anyway, I thought it's important to tell me what's going on. We glad it's going to be okay. But sorry to be ahead.
Thank you.
Those darn scooters. Yeah. Was it like a. accident, which involves some other person hitting him, or they just… No, yeah, he got his bounds, and he…
Well, he did tumble right? So yeah, yeah. Anyway, good to hear your voice now, Rude.
Okay, see you all enjoy the nice weather. Yeah, it's it's warming. Yeah.
Spring has always been too short. It transitions from winter to summer too late. Maybe you can just take the longest I've seen like the winter part luck at least.
Usually micro. Oh, no, there's been many snow before. Not for a couple of years, though, I feel like it's not snowing Easter one time.
I'm just sad that the weather hasn't been conducive to the world. It's just been windy every day. Yeah.
I like the window. I know Wendy's great, but you just can't think about those ones, except for electronic.
Yeah, nice to see you on a few years.
Just let us know if you guys need any more data. The only thing that we haven't really sent across is it's covered in, like, the earlier data set, but it's just, like, the dim schema for, like, how the staging is there.
So if you want me to send that across, do I?
The audio schema has it marked, right? It does. It has all the attributes to the categories. So this has all the attributes mapped correctly. So BIM schema is only only useful for you guys if you're actually mapping the data into like a final staging schema. But right now you're just looking at the output kind of thing. So it's not only relevant.
We're gonna have pretty significant rework of the pin schema, too. Yeah. But it should be fine for what you're doing, like we're just consolidating some tables, but it's still going to be the same idea of, like, you're just going to be outputting the safety table, which will allow for the difference. I mean, even in the meeting, you guys told that.
Uh, industry standards were still similar enough to what is currently there. I mean, the industry standards are always something we'd recommend you guys to work with. Yes.
Because those are standardized, they won't be affected by how we're feeling on a certain day, and it's always some of it.
You too! How to stop the morning.